Maya guides kin and bore will lead us to
the
mountain and Mexican archaeologist and
climber arcilia Garcia will help me
explore
it that's going to be the Red
Mountain looks like
it Chu
octune chuun or Red Mountain lies around
2 miles to the northwest of the
archaeological of no
coup I think I see some corar ANS are
those cor ANS right there
yeah just like in the
clips can I pass you the Rope
yeah let's
go
okay looks like there's a little Trail
up
here to tell the
mountain oh
okay
the ancient Maya believ that a powerful
God split a mountain with an axe
releasing sacred seeds from which human
life
originated this is a powerful place I
can feel it in my
[Music]
bones
what is
this
what you got to see what is
this WOW hole into the
[Music]
mountain mountains are
living breathing
things
wow I
hope I mean a mountain with a hollow
core this has to be the symbol that's
being referred to at pen you think this
is what this is see the Split
Mountain that's incredible let's go that
was that wow
hey Albert yeah there's another one over
here another
entrance it's got to be a connected Cave
System right
right if this is the hollow Mountain
these tunnels could be the entry point
we'll take one
each you take those yes you have a
radio when the ancient Maya discovered
mountains like those described in their
origin myths they became the center of
their spiritual
World we're going into a place that's
reserved for the gods or The Souls of
the
[Music]
Dead hope the gods are with
us
[Music]